m
et
[Applaudissements]
josy lannoy de situation sanitaire
catastrophique y aura fait nous coince
au nom des siens aux papilles et la
perte de chance au noir s'était dit
marcel azzola sinon il est hors de
question que nous vivons dans un pays où
les familles à nous rendre au chu
elles n'ont pas cette revue est sorti 12
il est venu la question que nous valons
pays où le graphène un coin kaïm a bossé
mais j'ose il à nous demander aux
services de soins de qualité de
proximité city cabane où l'excellence à
tout moment et n'ont pas tous les raison
des pénuries en bout les réseaux
d'approvisionnement sont des raisons de
gestion du personnel à y organiser nos
animaux qui lie ce n'est pas ce que nous
coûte un bras gauche josy la nounou a
souffert des situations là ça et donc
nous avons dépouillé force de travail
organisation va au ciné d'ailleurs la
cdm c'est sous les 1,20 nouveau dylan ou
s'affirmant au sénégal au niveau baisse
également mobilisés pour yom également
solidarité avesnois
donc
mes problèmes sont les mêmes à la menthe
et qu'elle a pas de lopins nous à la
martinique on a un établissement neuf on
a un manque du matériel de travail et ça
pose problème et fait maintenu jeudi à
la martinique
les bonnes âmes saint dié maty djigueul
où nous sommes ici dans le cadre du sud
a été entre les odeurs syndicale face à
nous de faire les tests aux spectacteurs
cas des centaines de cadets sommes pas
mis en place un établissement qui peut
prendre en charge des patients
la population martiniquaise elle nous
sauf difficultés à combler un manque
également tous les jours nous sommes des
soignants nous sommes des professionnels
du soin à l'heure actuelle nous conte
des mécaniciens au cateau qu on ne peut
plus travailler comme il faut comme des
professionnels parce qu'il nous manque
du matériel
il nous manque des moyens humains ils
manquent de tout il faut qu'on arrête
avec ses simagri on sait qu'il s'agit de
soigner la population point bas la
population paye des impôts la population
paie la sécurité sociale c'est pour
avoir les mêmes droits
la même égalité de chance lorsque vous
avez un problème en martinique en
guadeloupe au métropolis
[Musique]